how did I sell my product to have
customers in over 30 countries I'm going
to answer that question in today's
episode of ask Evan so I got a question
for one of my loyal youtube viewers love
you guys
crap stuff who wrote in to say bro you
sold a software company to Johnson
Johnson which is a huge company with
over 100 years of experience that means
your software was somehow unique I want
to know everything you're willing to
share I'm working with a web-based
software myself and no it's not easy
I'd be the happiest guy on the planet if
I had a software clients in over 30
countries how much you willing to share
let me know this is a great question and
just a note of clarification I didn't
sell my company to Johnson & Johnson I
sold it to a Japanese company but I sold
to Johnson Johnson as one of my clients
they bought our software and yes it was
really unique software the challenge we
had going in was that we already had
established competitors and they had
tons of features and the problem that my
partners came across they were the
researchers they had developed it was
that there was nothing that was easy to
use so our software didn't have the most
functionality the most features but it
was the easiest software to use on the
market and that's part of what helped us
get to our success but to answer your
question things I want to share I'm
going to share with you my three tips
that might help you grow your software
company as well so number one is get
distribution I struggled so much in the
early days in my software company I'm
told the store a couple times in this
channel where I had $300 a month I was
eating beans for lunch every day and
could barely survive and the thing that
helped me breakthrough was getting
distribution I looked at companies who
could represent us overseas and the
first deal I landed was four five
figures and when I had that check coming
it was unbelievable bogus finally now I
had some money coming into my business
and so what you want to first it was
look for people who are selling related
products to your target market and
figure out ways to partner up with them
how can you have them help rep your
product so that you're not off going
selling one at a time one
I'm one of the time but by connecting
with them and giving them a cut
everything they sell bill helping you
reach a lot more people
number two is have a free version but
really help us get some adoption is
having a free version of our software
for people to try for people to taste
for people that get a sense of what
we're all about because at the start
it's really risky to buy a new product
that we've never used that you've never
tried before and the more expensive it
is the more risk there is for someone to
want to get into your product so having
a free version where you can strip out
some functionality or give them a
time-limited trial
helps reduce the risk and allows people
to try your product make sure it's a
good product right make sure people can
use it and they love and they want to
come back something that they can't live
without anymore but having that free
version really helped us out and number
three is get exposure once we had that
free version that we knew people were
liking we knew people were upgrading
from my next job became how do I get
tons of exposure for my business to get
more and more people downloading the
free version I knew if I can get them on
the free version I can upsell them on
the main version so how do I get them
finding out about my business the main
path that I use was using the media and
I had some success with major media but
the biggest success I had with with
targeted industry specific media and I
tried to get my business partner who was
the scientist and researcher featured in
as many magazines and publications as
possible in our industry so people could
learn about us find out about us visit
our website and eventually get the free
version of our software and eventually
buy our product so that really helped us
if I was starting it over now I look at
not just a traditional media but also
the online media I look at who's really
popular on Twitter and on YouTube on
Instagram who's covering my market and
try to get my product mind my message in
their hands so they can help spread the
message for me so again just like
looking at the get distribution strategy
instead of me going one of the time one
of the time one of the time trying to
convince people to buy from me I'm
connecting to an influencer still
helping spread my message and it brings
a ton more people to visit my website so
get distribution have a
version and get exposure thank you so
much for watching good luck with your
business and you have a question for me
that you want me to answer in the next
version of ask Evan ask it below and
I'll see what I can do
continue to believe